Pero lo que vimos, en la era post 11-S,
es que usaron el secreto y la justificación del terrorismo
para empezar estos programas en secreto
sin consultar al Congreso,
ni al pueblo de EE.UU.,
y es de ese tipo de gobierno a puertas cerradas
del que tenemos que protegernos,
porque nos hace menos seguros
y no aporta valor.
CA: Bien, ven conmigo un segundo,
porque tengo una pregunta más personal para hacerte.
Hablando del terror,
muchas personas consideran tu situación actual
en Rusia muy aterrorizante.
Seguramente escuchaste lo que pasó,
el trato que recibió Bradley Manning,
ahora Chelsea Manning,
y salió una noticia en Buzzfeed diciendo que
hay personas en la comunidad de inteligencia
que te quieren muerto.
¿Cómo manejas esto?
¿Cómo manejas el miedo?
ES: No es ningún misterio
que hay gobiernos que me quieren ver muerto.
Lo dejé en claro una y otra vez,
que me voy a dormir todas las noches
pensando qué puedo hacer por el pueblo de EE.UU.
No quiero perjudicar a mi gobierno.
Quiero ayudar a mi gobierno,
pero el hecho de que quieran
ignorar por completo el debido proceso,
que quieran declarar culpables
sin siquiera un juicio previo,
estas son cosas contra las que tenemos que trabajar
como sociedad y decir que no es apropiado.
No deberíamos amenazar a los disidentes.
No deberíamos criminalizar al periodismo.
Y lo que sea que pueda hacer para ese fin,
lo haré con gusto a pesar de los riesgos.
CA: Me gustaría recibir algo de feedback
de la audiencia aquí presente,
porque sé que hay reacciones muy distintas
hacia Edward Snowden.
Imaginen que tienen las siguientes 2 opciones.
Consideran lo que hizo
fundamentalmente como un acto imprudente
que puso a EE.UU. en peligro,
o lo consideran un acto fundamentalmente heroico
que funcionará para EE.UU. y el mundo entero
a largo plazo.
Esas son las opciones que daré.
Me gustaría saber quién vota por
la primera opción,
la de un acto temerario.
Se levantan algunas manos.
Algunas manos arriba.
Es difícil levantar la mano
cuando tienes al hombre ahí enfrente,
pero veo algunas.
ES: Puedo verlos. (Risas)
CA: Y ¿quiénes van por la segunda opción
la de un acto heroico?
(Aplausos) (Ovación)
Creo que es cierto decir que hay muchas personas
que no levantaron la mano y creo
que todavía lo están pensando,
porque me parece que el debate
no se divide por las líneas políticas tradicionales.
No es izquierda o derecha, no se trata
de estar a favor del gobierno, de ser libertario ni nada de eso.
En parte es un problema generacional.
Uds. son parte de una generación que creció
con Internet y parece que
se ven ofendidos a un nivel casi visceral
si ven algo que
creen que puede dañar a Internet.
¿Hay algo de cierto en eso?
ES: Sí, creo que es cierto.
No se trata de ser de izquierda o derecha.
Nuestras libertadas básicas, y cuando digo nuestras,
no me refiero solo a los estadounidenses,
sino a las personas de todo el mundo,
no tiene que ver con un problema partidario.
Estas cosas en las que creen todas las personas,
y depende de todos nosotros protegerlas,
y de las personas que han visto y disfrutado
de una Internet libre y gratuita
depende de nosotros preservar esa libertad
para que la próxima generación pueda disfrutarla,
y si no cambiamos las cosas,
si no nos paramos para hacer los cambios
que hay que hacer para mantener la seguridad en Internet,
no solo por nosotros sino por todos,
vamos a perderla,
y será una pérdida tremenda,
para nosotros y para todo el mundo.
CA: Bueno, escuché un discurso similar hace poco
del fundador de la WWW
que creo que está con nosotros, Sir Tim Berners-Lee.
Tim, de hecho, quiere decir algo,
¿tenemos un micrófono para Tim?
(Aplausos)
Tim, qué bueno verte. Ven.
¿En qué bando estás, a propósito,
traidor o héroe? Tengo una teoría pero...
Tim Berners-Lee: He dado respuestas mucho más largas
a esa pregunta, pero héroe,
si tuviera que elegir entre las dos.
CA: Ed, creo que leíste
sobre la propuesta de Sir Tim donde hablaba
de hacer una nueva Carta Magna para recuperar Internet.
¿Tiene sentido?
ES: Por supuesto. Mi generación y yo
crecimos no solo pensando en Internet,
sino que crecimos en Internet,
y aunque nunca hubiese esperado tener la oportunidad
de defenderla de una manera tan directa y práctica
y encarnarla de esta manera
tan inusual y casi a lo Avatar,
creo que hay algo de poético en el hecho que
uno de los hijos de Internet
se ha vuelto cercano a Internet
como resultado de su expresión política.
Y creo que la Carta Magna para Internet
es justo lo que necesitamos.
Necesitamos codificar nuestros valores
no solo por escrito sino en la estructura de Internet,
es algo que espero
y los invito a todos en la audiencia,
no solo aquí en Vancouver sino en el mundo entero,
a unirse y participar.
CA: ¿Tienes una pregunta para Ed?
TBL: Bueno, 2 preguntas,
una pregunta general.
CA: ¿Ed, nos escuchas?
ES: Sí, los escucho. CA: Volvió.
TBL: Pincharon la línea
y hubo una interferencia por un momento.
(Risas)
ES: Es un problema de la NSA.
TBL: Desde los 25 años,
volviendo atrás y pensando,
¿qué dirías que es
lo mejor que hemos logrado
a partir de todas las discusiones que tuvimos
sobre la web que queremos?
ES: Pensando en términos
de qué tan lejos podemos ir,
creo que es una pregunta que solo está limitada
por lo que queremos poner dentro.
Creo que la Internet que disfrutamos en el pasado
fue exactamente lo que nosotros como nación
y como personas del mundo entero necesitábamos,
y cooperando, dedicándonos no solo
a las partes técnicas como sociedad,
sino, como dijiste tú, los usuarios
las personas de todo el mundo que contribuyen
a través de Internet, de la redes sociales,
los que miran el clima,
los que confían en ello como parte de su vida,
tenemos que defender eso.
Tendremos no solo la Internet que tuvimos,
sino una mejor Internet, un mejor presente,
algo que podamos usar para construir el futuro
que será mejor de lo que esperamos
y de lo que jamás hemos imaginado.
CA: Hace 30 años que se fundó TED, en 1984.
Hubo muchas charlas desde entonces
siguiendo el razonamiento de que
en realidad George Orwell estaba equivocado.
No hay un Gran Hermano que nos mira.
Nosotros, gracias al poder de la Web,
y la transparencia, estamos mirando al Gran Hermano.
De alguna manera, tus revelaciones le dieron una puñalada
al corazón de esa mirada más bien optimista,
pero todavía crees que hay algo para hacer
al respecto.
Y tú también.
ES: Exacto, se puede argumentar
que los poderes del Gran Hermano han aumentado muchísimo.
Hace poco salió un artículo legal en Yale
que establecía el principio Bankston-Soltani
que decía que nuestra expectativa de privacidad es violada
cuando las capacidades de vigilancia del gobierno
se vuelven más baratas en un orden de magnitud,
y cada vez que eso sucede, tenemos que
revisar y reequilibrar nuestros derechos de privacidad.
Eso no ha sucedido desde
que los poderes de vigilancia del gobierno
aumentaron en varios órdenes de magnitud,
y por eso tenemos el problema que tenemos hoy
pero todavía hay esperanza,
porque los poderes de los individuos
también se incrementaron con la tecnología.
Soy una prueba viviente
de que un individuo puede ir cabeza a cabeza
contra los adversarios más poderosos
y las agencias de inteligencia más poderosas
del mundo y ganar,
y creo que eso es algo
que nos da esperanza,
y tenemos que construir sobre eso
para que sea accesible no solo para los expertos técnicos
sino también para los ciudadanos comunes.
El periodismo no es un delito,
la comunicación no es un delito
y no tienen que monitorear nuestras actividades cotidianas.
CA: No sé cómo se le da la mano a un bot,
pero me imagino que la mano es esta. TBL: Pronto llegará.
ES: Un placer conocerte,
espero que me vean tan bien
como yo los veo a Uds.
CA: Gracias, Tim.
(Aplausos)
El New York Times pidió una amnistía para ti.
¿Aceptarías una oportunidad para volver a EE.UU.?
ES: Claro. Sin dudas,
los principios que han sido el fundamento
de este proyecto
han sido el interés público
y los principios que subyacen
al establishment periodístico de EE.UU.
y del mundo,
y creo que la prensa ahora dice
apoyamos esto,
esto es algo que tenía que pasar,
es un argumento fuerte pero no es el argumento final,
es el público el que debe decidir.
Pero al mismo tiempo,
el gobierno dio a entender que quiere
un tipo de acuerdo,
que quieren que comprometa
a los periodistas con los que trabajé,
a regresar,
y quiero dejar en claro
que no hice esto para estar a salvo.
Hice esto para hacer lo correcto,
y no voy a detener mi trabajo
en interés del público
solo para beneficiarme.
(Aplausos)
CA: Mientras tanto,
por cortesía de Internet y la tecnología,
estás de vuelta en América del Norte,
no en EE.UU., sino en Canadá.
¿Qué se siente?
ES: Canadá es diferente de lo que pensaba.
Es mucho más cálido.
(Risas)
CA: En TED, la misión es "Ideas que vale la pena difundir".
Si pudieras encapsular todo en una idea,
¿cuál sería tu idea que vale la pena difundir
en este momento?
ES: Diría que el año pasado fue un recordatorio
de que la democracia puede morir detrás de puertas cerradas,
pero los individuos nacemos
detrás de esas mismas puertas cerradas,
y no tenemos que ceder
nuestra privacidad para tener un buen gobierno.
No tenemos que ceder nuestra libertad
para tener seguridad.
Trabajando juntos
podemos tener un gobierno honesto
y vidas privadas,
y espero trabajar con todos
en el mundo entero para que esto pase.
Muchas gracias.
CA: Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)